alors que la france est sans doute à
l'aube d'un troisième confinement les
experts ne vois pas comment nous
pourrions échapper à un troisième
complètement et que le restaurateur sont
à l'agonie partout à travers le monde
des scènes de réveillon lieu en italie
aux pays-bas est désormais en france
[Musique]
plus précisément à nice où ce midi le
patron du pot peas christophe wilson a
décidé de rouvrir ses portes et ses
actes libertaire sont-ils inconscient en
pleine pandémie
ce restaurateur doit-il être sévèrement
condamné ce soir stéphane manigold et
sur notre plateau en soutien à tous les
restaurateurs de france c'est pas d'ma
nicole est avec le président du
collectif restons ouverts et on va vous
montrer ce qui s'est passé ce midi
devant le popiste plus de 50 personnes
sans masque à tabler sur la terrasse
couverte de l'établissement ont répondu
présent à l'appel de christophe wilson
le gérant évidemment les images ont fait
le boss toute la journée sur les réseaux
ceux ci ont regardé une fois de plus ces
images
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
si c'est moi qui doit être le
déclencheur pour que pour qu'on reprenne
tous nos responsabilités qu'on reprenne
le contrôle de notre vie je l'assumé
pleinement
[Applaudissements]
alors merci stéphane manigold et un
rythme qui est pour quiconque dit oui
vous êtes tout est dit tout et vous
edwards edwards pilote pour condamner
mais où bien sûr km condé y appelait il
ya plein de restaurateurs aujourd'hui
qui ont pas pu ouvrir leur restaurant et
il n'y a pas que des restaurateurs il ya
des chefs de pme il ya plein de gens qui
font les plans sociaux partout il ya
aujourd'hui trois mille personnes en
réanimation
on continue à remonter très très fort
vous êtes en angleterre avec 1600 morts
par jour il ya un moment donné je sais
que c'est une crise sociale sans
précédent que la pandémie on apprend à
vivre avec
mais aujourd'hui pourquoi un
restaurateur pourrait ouvrir et pas les
autres
alors évidemment si tu parle d'autre
chose
excuse moi ce monsieur c'est un
restaurateur il est donc à nice il voit
depuis un an il a vu pendant 2 3 mois
l'aîné des français aller à monaco dans
les restaurants ils voient les français
qui vont à madrid dans les restaurants
il se dit pourquoi moi je vais rester
ferme et puis moi je vais continuer à
crever à quoi au fait finalement quand
on peut aller ailleurs on y va je
comprends évidemment sa position et
effectivement il ya une crise sanitaire
mais comme les gens maintenant l'ordi
tout et leur contraire le en même temps
ils n'en peuvent plus et je comprends
très bien
sa réaction parce qu'effectivement quand
on voit ce qui se passe ailleurs on ne
comprend plus effectivement à sa place
et les voies y voit les que je finis ils
voient les cantines des sociétés qui
sont ouvertes
ils vont aller les cantines des écoles
qui souriait des pourquoi moi je peux
pas et au bout du bout il est forcément
très examen dit n'importe quoi ses
interrogateurs il l'avait déjà fait lors
du premier confinement il à 300 mètres
du commissariat il fait exprès à chaque
fois et moi ce qui me désole c'est que
la police est venue n'a pas réussi à le
faire fermer
donc c'est invraisemblable ce qui s'est
passé c'est honteux il faut qu'il soit
attaqué pour mise en danger de la vie
d'autrui
c'est tout simple c'est un an de prison
15 mille euros d'amendé
mais stéphane stoll qui est président du
collectif restons ouverts alors vous
remercie de alors de nous donner la
parole le collectif restons ouverts
comme son indic c'est pour que demain on
puisse rester ouverts il s'agit pas de
massacrer nos entreprises aujourd'hui
mais ce qui s'est passé avec ce
restaurateur j'étais le premier à
considérer que j'allais l'aider avec des
avocats si ils étaient en infraction
parce que je comprends cette colère qui
aujourd'hui est puissante et au delà des
restaurateurs et les puissantes auprès
des chefs d'entreprises des français des
françaises mais il s'est mis en
infraction et moi je n'appelle pas une
insurrection du pays et il faut que le
président de la république comprenne que
les français et françaises
nous les chefs d'entreprise nous sommes
plus d'un million dans ce pays nous
avons une énergie et cette énergie est
utilisée pour faire face à ce [ __ ] de
virus et qu'ils cessent de circuler dans
le pays
les restaurants pourquoi on va ouvrir
parce qu'on a envie de travailler mais
on ne parlait pas désirées sont sales
alors les écoles elles ont des problèmes
nous étudions sont entassés dans les
universités ils sont entassés dans les
collèges où on au restaurant pour
nourrir nos gamins nous sommes autour
des collèges des lycées
ouvrons mettons à disposition pour qu'on
puisse travailler et nourrir nos enfants
pas s'ils sont assez eh bien s'ils
peuvent être ans s'est entassée là bas
ou des hangars sont un peu nos lycées
nous écoles pour que demain puisqu'un
troisième confinement qui arrivent et
baglo gamme a pu arriver quand aulas
dans les jours cyril on dit que le chef
de l'état a parlé samedi soir oui mais
mais vous savez nous on fait tout pour
que l'on puisse avoir une activité dans
ce pays les chefs d'entreprise 26% des
chefs d'entreprises ont déjà pause pensé
à se suicider cyril c'est les chiffres
de bercy
nous avons rudy un restaurateur vosgien
et je vais rejoindre ceux qui sont
contre l'appel à l'insurrection rudy
restaurateurs vosgien qui s'est suicidé
cyril il a pris une fermeture
administrative de deux mois et les
conséquences sont lourdes
le préfet a ramené à 15 jours et il a
fini par se suicider dans son restaurant
il ya des drames d'air tout cela et
toutes celles et ceux qui appellent à
l'insurrection
il faut qu'ils comprennent une chose
c'est que derrière la sanction les
lourdes au delà de la sanction pénale
au delà de tout ça plus fonctionner à
rite et mise en danger d'autrui mise en
danger pour les hôpitaux
nous avons de nombreux médecins qui sont
à nos côtés qui comprennent le
souffrance et qui font tout pour mettre
en place des protocoles sanitaires
nous devons au sein du collectif restons
ouverts et c'est le cas être force de
proposition nous avons l'énergie
nous voulons lutter ensemble
efficacement contre la propagation de ce
virus
nous voulons travailler mais cette
énergie doit être utilisé à bon escient
voile contre ce genre de pratique en
tout cas c'est ce que vous dites mais
cyril je vais vous faire une confidence
mais il y a deux choses qu'il faut
distinguer si ce restaurateur était dans
une situation catastrophique
économiquement
croyez moi que dès demain matin on va
contacter bercy pour l'aider si c'est le
cas
mais il ya aussi des businessman de la
misère qui aujourd'hui pénalise plus de
cent mille chefs d'entreprises qui n'ont
toujours pas reçu le fonds de solidarité
du moins de décembre parce qu'il ya des
businessman de la misère et croyant à
une chose c'est vrai c'est vrai donc
collectif restons ouverts j'en ai eu ce
matin au téléphone je peux vous dire que
je vais reçu 1
il n'y a pas de place pour ces
businessman moi j'aide celles et ceux
qui souffrent et oui cyril je suis déjà
allée mois dans un restaurant
clandestins mais un mec qui était au
bord du gouffre je ne pouvais plus qui
respecte et par contre les gestes
sanitaire pas plus de 6 dans son
restaurant juste pour bouffer lui l'a
pas respecté les règles sanitaires
il avait pas de masquer le son
restaurant était trop plein son chef et
selon la préfecture
là on vient de recevoir l'annoncent la
préfecture des alpes maritimes vient de
dire que son chef était en position
tessa d'irrégularités exactement 16 ans
vient de recevoir ces les informations
que nous avons mais nous on est là pour
aider ceux qui sont bord du gouffre il
faut pas les condamner il faut les aider
et les aider c'est ce qu'ont fait tous
les jours encore jusque là juste avant
l'émission
j'étais avec des collaborateurs de
mercier pour parler de situations
dramatiques les businessmans de la
misère sur le compte facebook restons
ouverts cyril ils n'ont pas leur place
ceux qui sont dans la détresse
on les
et on va continuer à les aider vous
rendez compte à quel point la question
qu'on est en train de se poser les
lunaire on se demande si un homme est
sévèrement condamnés pour ouvrir un
restaurant c'est des faits qui étaient
totalement légaux il ya encore quelques
mois
et pardon mais lui il a le courage de
faire à visage découvert ce que plein de
restaurateurs et je les soutiens et je
mets pas tout le reste en attendant m
tian ils font de manière clandestine et
ils ont raison il ya plein de restaurer
vous êtes vous avez été dans un resto
aujourd'hui à paris il ya plein de
restaurants ici ouvre la gorge par
israël ils ont raison de le faire il ya
pas élégant sans lag dirigeants devaient
faire pour les aider un choc mais on
peut pas oublier nos médecins on peut
pas les appeler comme et confinant nous
on a cuisiné pendant le premier
confinement pour tout le personnel de
santé et on continuera à le faire mais
il faut que le président de la
république et je sais que vous avez de
bons rapports avec lui que vous
dialoguez il faut qui vous écoutent et
qui nous écoutent ce soir et qui est qui
et qui libère cette énergie pour qu'on
puisse cuisiner pour les restos du coeur
pour qu'on puisse mets cuisinés pour le
personnel de santé pour campus cuisiner
pour nos gamins qui doivent continuer à
aller à l'école et compris avec ce
confinement qui est imminent imminent
mais je suis en train de se fût ce
qu'est de ce monsieur qui fait ça à
visage découvert alors qu'aujourd'hui
dans les grandes villes et surtout à
paris ya plein de restaurants qu'ils le
font à midi un peu moins le charme à ce
qui a beaucoup de contrôle et que c'est
une réalité
et maintenant il faut l'accepter il ya
de plus en plus de rue les gens il
commence encore plus rien à [ __ ] ouais
j'aime quand ça joue parfaitement la
misère les restaurateurs et je suis tout
comme avec mieux les restes en d'accord
et des chefs d'entrée mais antoine est
en train de cautionner
mais en tant que passionné l'ouverture
clandestine des restaurants non mais
c'est invraisemblable il ya surtout des
gens qui font à la gorge volet non mais
janot les forces de provisions ce que
nous faisons
new york par exemple j'ai un copain qui
m'a envoyé des photos de restaurants ils
sont en terrasse ils peuvent travailler
en terrasse avec des distances il faut
pas être manichéen sur ces sujets il
faut ouvrir le dialogue oui et c'est
légal des offres et tous ces on n'a pas
le droit mais non mais non
et là on n'a pas le droit à paris
justement travail ont intelligemment
canton puisse avoir le droit a pas me
faire et en toute sécurité nous
travaillons avec les scientifiques lé
comité scientifique pour que justement
on puisse sortir de cette crise il y à
une crise profonde une angoisse
n'oubliez pas les chefs nos chefs
la france le repas gascon et des
français il est classé au patrimoine
immatériel de l'unesco au patrimoine
mondial et nos chefs ce sont des
athlètes de haut niveau de haut niveau
le monde entier vient dans notre pays
pour goûter nos cuisines et nous
agriculteurs rêves et nos vignerons
crève tout ça et écosystèmes toute cette
chaîne je prenais un peu d'air s'est pas
gêné j'ai peur pour vous savez que vous
êtes bien je vous ai beaucoup et j'ai
peur pour vous savez que je vous aime
énormément
oui mais pas envie qu'ils arrivent à
passer toute la journée je passe mon
temps à répondre à des messages de
détresse qu on fait que ça toute la
journée
mais pourquoi parce que quand on est un
petit parmi les gros ce qui est mon cas
ouais eh bien on a un devoir de
bienveillance vis-à-vis des plus petits
on doit les aider
regardez le restaurateur niçois qui a
ouvert ses portes il est trop sévèrement
condamnés oui à 44% non à 56 alors sens